okay welcome back to class everyone so
this is the second second week of class
the second week of complex analysis and
the last week of complex analysis
probably so I'm almost ready to tell you
the most important facts from complex
analysis that we're going to use when we
solve partial differential equations and
the plas transforms inverse Laplace
transforms and so on so things are
building up and getting interesting now
what did we learn about complex
functions in the last class forward kind
of the most important things we've been
learning about complex functions so far
some of them are some of the complex
functions are analytical and what does
it mean to be an analytic function in
the complex plane sorry I say again okay
you can take the derivative what else
yeah it has a convergent Taylor series
what else sorry the real and imaginary
part solve Laplace's equations yep so
they're harmonic functions super
important what else what do they look
like what's the shape and geometry of
these functions they're basically smooth
smooth is another word for
differentiable and what are some
examples of non analytic features that
are not smooth singularities so if I
just have like a black hole or what else
step functions if I had cusps like I'm
just making real valued analogue it's
like a cusp is not differentiable at
that point so that wouldn't work either
so basically at this point we have a
pretty good idea of what analytic means
maybe not the most mathematically
rigorous set of definitions ever but we
we have a gut feeling for what an
analytic function means and so today
what we're going to talk about is how to
handle simple functions that are barely
not analytic
they're basically analytic everywhere
except of a couple of singularities okay
so I'm just gonna say recall from last
lecture that if f of Z is analytic in
sub domain D then the closed contour
integral of F equals 0 if C is closed
and it's a subset of D and E has to be a
simply connected domain which means that
it doesn't have any holes in it so I'm
just gonna draw this picture one more
time because it's really important so we
have our complex plane and let's say I
have some nice domain D that doesn't
have any holes in it
ok and if I have any closed contour C
inside of this domain so it can be some
weird-looking thing but as long as it's
closed and it's inside this nice simply
connected domain D then this contour
integral integral around C of my
function equals 0 right that was one
major major result that we had this is
the Koshi Gore saw theorem really
important ok any questions about this ok
we also had the fact that if we had a
maybe a a weird domain that is not
simply connected so maybe there's some
weird singularities in here
I can take any two clothed contours and
continuously deform them into each other
so this red contour has the same
integral as this red contour okay
and we prove that in the last class kind
of geometrically by doing some surgery
and using the Kochi course off theorem
that was the last thing we did on the
last lecture okay these integrals let's
call this c1 and c2 so integral around C
1 equals integral around C 2 but those
do not necessarily equal 0 because the
singularities might mess up my
integration okay one last thing just in
case I just want to test to make sure
that everyone's understanding things
pretty well so let's say that we have
that case with some singularities in the
middle what if I have my integral here
what if that is C then the integral
around C of f of zdz
is what zero right because it's in a
domain D that's simply connected and
it's analytic in that domain good all
right ok so we're ready to do some
pretty cool stuff now I'm gonna do a
couple of things throughout the lecture
today and on Wednesday one of the things
that we're gonna do is we're gonna start
thinking about so we know that these two
contour integrals equal each other but
we don't know we don't know what it
equals what these integrals equal so
we're gonna start figuring out how to do
contour integrals in analytic domains
that surround singularities okay this is
gonna be a very common thing that we're
gonna do this is going to come up in
Laplace transforms a lot so we're gonna
try to figure out what dis equals it's
good that they equal each other but we
also want to know what they actually
themselves so that's one thing we're
gonna do we're gonna coat it up in
MATLAB and actually start computing
these contour integrals you know
numerically by hand to confirm our
mathematical intuition and then we're
going to use these results to solve some
really difficult and really important
integrals that we didn't think we could
solve before okay so that's the agenda
for the next two lectures maybe three
and once I've done that I'm pretty much
happy with what you know about complex
analysis okay
there will be little bits here and there
that I'll tell you about okay okay so
all polynomials and convergent power
series are analytic okay this is
something I've already told you it's
true and so we have examples like if you
have Z minus a to the power n that's a
polynomial in Z a is just a complex
number so this is it's analytic for N
equals one two three depth ops and it's
not analytic for n equals minus 1 minus
2 minus 3 dot dot okay so if I had
positive powers of n here this would
just be a normal polynomial and it would
yes in fact the analytic but if I had
something like 1 over Z minus a or 1
over Z minus a squared or cubed or to
the fourth or whatever these are not
analytic these have singularities at Z
equals a alright there's a singularity
at Z equals a here singularity at Z
equals a here blows up to infinity ok
so what we're gonna figure out is how to
do contour integrals around these types
of functions for all powers of n these
are going to be building blocks we're
going to figure out how to do these
contour integrals and it's going to tell
us how to do other more interesting
contour integrals okay good so okay so
case one is for let's see case one is
for N equals one two three dot dot dot
and N equals -2 minus three minus four
dot dot dots in case two is going to be
N equals minus one okay this is a little
bit weird why am i why am I having this
special case here where n is minus one
and all of the other cases up here it's
because if I integrate this polynomial
or this this power function of Z minus a
for any of these powers I get that the
integral of Z minus a to the N DZ is
equal to Z minus a to the n plus one
divided by n plus one and you can
evaluate that at the starting and end
points of this contour which for a
closed loop our Z naught to Z naught
equals zero this is just because these
functions are easy to integrate we can
actually integrate you know Z minus a to
the N just like we did from regular
calculus except if n was negative one
what's the integral of one over Z minus
a log of Z minus a so that's why it's
its own special case here because it's
different
so that equals log of Z minus a
evaluated somehow on this contour I'm
gonna say Z naught plus two Z naught
minus I'll tell you what I mean by that
in a minute okay
maybe I'll just call this from Z 1 to Z
2 and this is not equal to 0 because our
log function of Z is multivalued okay
remember we have let's say that this is
real Z imaginary of Z and this is the
imaginary part of Z of log Z then we
have this kind of spiral staircase thing
that goes forever in the positive and
negative direction so for example if I
do a closed loop see that contains the
point 0 let's say that my closed loop in
the real plane looked like that
then in log I'm actually going all the
way up here and I've just picked up a
factor of 2 pi in the imaginary
direction okay
so intuitively I'm going to prove this
we're going to go through like the
actual math and show that this is
exactly what we get but what we actually
get is that this integral does not equal
0 it equals 2 pi I ok and I'm going to
I'm actually going to show that this is
true in two different ways this is just
a cartoon and this is just to convince
you that it might be more interesting
than 0 ok so what do we have just to
summarize so all polynomials with
positive powers are analytic and so they
have to integrate to 0 right we know
that but
- a - a negative power like negative 2
negative 3 negative 4 are not analytic
but most of them also integrate to zero
because they're just easy to integrate
and they cancel out ok the only case
that doesn't integrate to zero is the
power of negative 1 so if I contour
integral 1 over Z minus a that is the
only power of Z minus a that when you
have a closed contour integral will not
equal 0 I just want you to know the
basic facts before we start proving
things this is really really important
because almost every power of Z minus a
to the N integrates to 0 except this one
very special one yeah
these all include any closed curve this
is true for for any C especially those
that include Z minus a and here what if
my closed curve was out here in the real
and imaginary axis that contour integral
of 1 over Z minus a would equal 0
because it's actually analytic out here
ok so this is only if your contour
integral encloses Z equals a that things
get weird yeah I mean we're defining
this contour integral to be one rotation
in Z in the Z plane
trying to think if I could make a weird
contour that had more and I'm sure I
could I guess I could do something like
that and now I have two enclosures and I
would give me a 4pi okay so let's let's
see why this is true
okay so we're gonna have two different
approaches to show that this case 2 is
equal to 2 pi I I'm gonna flip the order
in my notes because I think that the
case so two approaches to show that the
integral of 1 over Z minus ad Z equals 2
pi I ok so first let's just do this
integral like we have so we have
integral of C DZ over Z minus a is equal
to log of Z evaluated at I'm gonna call
them z1 and z2 for now but really what
we have is that this log of Z we can
expand as its log of the radius of Z
alright Z equals R e to the I theta log
at the radius plus I times theta plus 2
pi K ok and here we're integrating from
0 to 2 pi in theta this is in theta so
the way we think about this is that our
contour integral whatever it was
remember by that theorem we can deform
this into another contour integral that
has a fixed constant radius and that's
what we're going to be integrating here
so we're integrating with a constant
radius and we're integrating in theta
from 0 to 2 pi ok so when you plug all
this in the constant radius you
essentially get log of R minus log of R
and whatever K is you get 2 pi K minus 2
pi K and the only thing that comes out
of this integral after you evaluate it
to
and at zero is two pi minus zero okay so
essentially what we did was we deformed
our contour C onto a circle
and then we just integrated in polar
coordinates from theta equals zero to
2pi okay so another more formal way to
do that which is essentially the same
thing that we're doing we're going to
deform our curve onto a circle and so we
have Z minus a equals R e to the I theta
sorry this is centered around the point
a so it's really Z minus a is our e to
the I theta okay so if this is Z minus a
then what is DZ what is my differential
DZ
how do I take the exact differential of
of this thing
well Z is just this plus a constant a
and so the differential is the
derivative of this with respect to R dr
plus the derivative of this with respect
to theta d-theta
now R is completely not changing so DRS
zero and I just get I are each of the I
theta d-theta
and this is because R is constant
because we deformed our contour onto a
circle okay and so this is you know now
it's actually pretty easy to evaluate
this so we're going to integrate from C
Z minus a inverse DZ is the same as
integrating with a constant R from theta
equals 0 to 2 pi and we're gonna
integrate DZ divided by Z minus a so I
our eetu the i theta over r e to the I
theta D theta and lo and behold all of
these terms cancel right my Z minus a
cancels with my DZ and all that's left
is this little I and so that equals the
integral from 0 to 2 pi of I D theta
which equals 2 pi I
okay so that's three ways that I've
shown you how to integrate this simple
first-order pole at a we can actually
expand log out and evaluate log across
one of these branches we can go to polar
coordinates directly and actually
integrate from zero to 2pi and that's
the same thing that we have here
pictorially which is when we do a closed
curve in the Z plane we climb to another
branch of log and we picked up two pi I
in the process okay the basic fact that
matters and this is you know years from
now you probably won't remember all of
the details of how to prove this but the
thing that matters is this this is
really what matters the closed integral
of the 1 over Z minus a is equal to 2 pi
and that's the only interesting case
everything else goes to 0 ok there'll be
a lot more stuff we can do with this
this is probably one of the most
important results in complex analysis ok
any questions about this
okay so log of Z is multivalued which is
why when we go around we jump to a new
value and we add two pi I this function
is single value its inverse is multi
value remember when we took the fourth
root of one we had four values and we
took the third root of negative one we
had three values the inverse of a
integer power of Z is multivalued but
this is single value there's only one
value to this function and so going
around you don't you don't climb to a
new branch because there's only one
branch of this that's kind of
pictorially you know it doesn't have
this weird spiral staircase geometry
even if this thing has a singularity
it's still you know going down or maybe
it's you know going up but it doesn't
when you go around you're not on a new
branch like you are with log because
this function is single value that's
pictorially why it's true even though
it's not analytic it still has this
simple simple branch geometry there's
kind of one branch of this okay good
other questions
okay try and think of what order to tell
you things in for the maximal impact
okay so I'll tell you today is really
important I told you this basic most
important results this is really really
really really important and I'm going to
call it pivotal and I think I know how
to spell pivotal now there's a Oh
pivotal okay and I'm going to show you
the next most pivotal results and I'm
going to try to do it in time to show
you how to code it up in MATLAB like
we're doing on the homework okay so
armed with this results we can say
something very interesting
okay so this is another named formula
the Cauchy integral formula
I call it CIF sometimes okay and the
basic idea is the following let's say
that we have a function f which is
analytic everywhere and then we divide
it by Z minus a so we insert a
singularity at Z minus a ok so if F of Z
is analytic you know inside and on a
closed curve C and if the point a this a
is just a complex number so I'm going to
say it's in the complex plane so some
complex number a and if a is in the side
our contour C then I'm going to draw a
picture in a minute ok then the integral
around that contour of my function
divided by Z minus a is equal to 2 pi I
times my function evaluated at that
special point a
okay and I'm gonna draw this picture
because it's really really important
okay
so I have some domain D that's nice and
simply connected and I have some contour
C inside of there so if I didn't have
this denominator what would my integral
be zero right because f is analytic
inside of D so this contour integral of
f of z would be zero but there is some
point a here in the middle where I'm
artificially adding in a singularity at
a right I'm adding in a pole at Z equals
a this blows up to infinity and this
integral no longer equals zero because
it's not like this functions not
analytic and B anymore but using the
result we just proved we're going to be
able to show that this integral equals
two pi times the function value at a F
is defined at a F is smooth at a like we
have an F of a it's this function that
blows up at Z equals a and we're gonna
find that lots and lots and lots of
difficult integrals that we want to do
can be written in this form so for
example if you do an inverse Laplace
transform you're going to have something
like e to the minus s T divided by s
minus a right that looks a lot like an
inverse Laplace transform the bounds are
going to be weird but you're gonna have
an analytic function with a pole at Z
equals it okay this is something we'll
we'll do probably on Wednesday is
actually use this formula to take the
inverse Laplace transform instead of
using look-up tables we can actually
derive them now
okay so this is called the Cauchy
integral formula super super important
it's actually pretty easy to prove that
this is true okay any idea is how I
might go about doing this
what would you you let's say you wanted
to show that this is true how would you
go about taking this integral
I'll let you think about it for a little
while
well what is this looks a lot like this
term looks a lot like the integral of F
of a divided by Z minus a DZ around my
contour right F of a is just a number
and if I took that number times this
integral right I would get F of a times
my contour integral of 1 over Z minus a
DZ and what is this contour integral
equal to pi I so that is 2 pi F of a
which is what I end up getting so that
looks a lot like this so what I can do
is the following so I'm going to
essentially take my big integral that's
in the red box and I'm going to break it
up into that integral that I wrote on
the bottom plus the remainder and I'm
going to show that the remainder has to
equal 0 ok good so what do we have we
have the integral of f of Z divided by Z
minus a DZ around my contour I can break
it up into two integrals I can say that
this is equal to the integral of F of a
DZ over Z minus a plus the integral of F
of Z minus F of a divided by Z minus a
right if I add these two together then
my F of a is cancel and I get the
integral that I'm trying to solve okay
so we just showed that this I won this
first integral is equal to two pi I f of
a and what we're going to show now is
that the second integral equals zero
thus proving that this equals two pi F
of a okay so now we have to show that I
two equals zero which we can do okay so
I have some contour and I have some
point a and so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to take this integral and I'm
going to shrink it so that I'm very very
very close to this point a we can do
that right this expression here has a
singularity at Z equals a but it's
analytic everywhere else so I can take
this big curve here and I can
continuously deform it until it's kind
of epsilon close to the singularity I
can make it a little circle as small as
I want around that singularity this is
I'm all amusing the formula that we
derived in the last part of the last
lecture that you can continuously deform
these integrals in a domain that's
analytic okay
and so I'm gonna call this a little C
Delta it's a delta circle C Delta is a
delta radius circle around my point a so
I to is this thing and I can
continuously deform this contour into C
Delta of Athens
- F of a divided by Z minus a doozie
okay now when you learned calculus how
many of you learned about deltas and
epsilon Delta Epsilon proofs and what it
means to be able to take the limits so
the idea of something being
differentiable is that F of Z minus F of
a let's say that I want to choose Z
let's say that I want F of Z minus F of
a to be less than Epsilon so I can do
this for any epsilon you name by
choosing Z - a less than Delta so what
this means for a function to be
differentiable for a function to be
smooth and for the derivative to exist
at a point a then for any epsilon you
can name I can give you a delta such
that if my Z is Delta close to a then my
f of z is epsilon close to FF a this is
the Delta Epsilon definition of the
limits and derivative okay and so the
idea is I'm gonna make this numerator
less than Epsilon super super small
Epsilon and I can do that by choosing
Delta smaller and smaller and smaller so
this integral is less than or equal to
or maybe the absolute value of my
integral is less than or equal to the
integral of epsilon divided by Z minus a
DZ over C Delta now I do pick up a two
pi I here but I get two pi I times
Epsilon
and I can choose so my function f was in
fact analytic at this point it is
differentiable so I can do this Delta
Epsilon type proof for any epsilon you
name I could do it for epsilon is 1
millionth or 1 billionth or 1 times 10
to the minus a bajillion and I can take
the limit as epsilon goes to 0 and I can
make this Delta circle smaller and
smaller and smaller and I can force this
integral to be less than or equal to any
epsilon you can name that's positive
which is another way of saying that the
second integral has to equal 0 I can
bound it from above by any positive real
number you can name you name a number
I'll make my circle that much smaller
and will make I less than that number ok
this is just a long way of saying that
the second integral equals 0 this f of z
part and the only thing that we're left
with is this contour integral with F of
a in the numerator which establishes
this Koshi integral formula
ok really important formula important
enough to get some stars I feel bad I
just realized this morning that if
anyone was color blind then this
wouldn't make any sense or at least you
wouldn't get the extra emphasis so I
apologize this is going to make it
possible for us to solve lots and lots
and lots of powerful integrals that we
could have never solved in the real the
real domain ok there's a story that one
time Fineman was doing a really
important calculation and he used an
integral table for one of the integrals
he had and it happened to be a wrong
like a mistake a typo in the integral
table which he then found out later
because this formulas weren't working
and he vowed to never do another
integral using a table this is before
Mathematica
he vowed to never do another integral
using a table again so we always did
them by hand and this is probably the
single most useful formula for computing
really nasty integrals by hand okay so
all of those crazy integrals that
Mathematica can do and that are in
look-up tables that you have no idea how
to do you can basically solve them using
this formula and some tricks that I'm
going to show you on Wednesday and
Friday okay so I'm going to code some of
this up in MATLAB and we're going to do
this example for a couple of analytic
functions like we're gonna choose f to
be e to the Z or sine of Z or Co sub Z
some analytic function and then we're
going to add in a singularity and show
that we get this true result any
questions before we do that
who remembers what the function is in
the homework that I am doing sorry
probably for eight yeah G of Z and sine
of Z okay then I'll do Co sub Z let me
just double check
okay good yeah easy silence you okay so
what we're going to do is we're going to
in the complex plane I'm gonna make
these I'm gonna make this contour around
zero so a is going to equal zero so
we're gonna put in a pole at a equals
zero and we're gonna do an integral
around a circle with radius equal to one
and we're gonna show that this Koshi
integral formula is true okay clear all
clothes LLC you'll see we're gonna have
lets have N equals a thousand segments
in my circle so let's break my circle up
into a thousand little sectors we're
gonna say my integral equals zero starts
at zero and I'm going to add up the
contribution from each of those sectors
and D theta equals two pi divided by n
okay so each of my little wedges each of
my little slices of pie is gonna be two
pi divided by N and as a thousand four K
equals one to n my theta at that value
of K is 2 pi times K divided by n we're
just counting from k 1 to N we're gonna
say my function equals let's say f of Z
equals coasts of Z so my function Z is
just coasts of sorry Z is r times e to
the I theta right my variables are e to
the I theta R is constant one
and my function f is gonna be coasts DZ
equals I times e to the I theta times D
theta okay and my F is gonna be coasts
of Z so all I've done at this point I've
just find some complex variable Z and
that complex variable Z is going from
you know angle 0 increasing all the way
to angle to PI DZ I'm just taking the
derivative of this with respect to theta
I get IR e to the I theta D theta where
D theta is like a little tiny D theta
wedge my function is coasts and we're
gonna have I equals I plus DZ times F so
I'm not doing this integral yet first of
all I'm just integrating around cosine
so what is a closed contour integral
around the function cosine equal I'm
really hoping this is 0 because I know
cosine is analytic test CIF okay and I
should probably output what I is
and in fact my output is within machine
precision of 0 right tiny tiny tiny tiny
real part plus tiny tiny tiny tiny
imaginary part good so we verified that
this contour integral around a unit
radius circle of an analytic function is
0 if you try a different analytic
function let's try it it on let's try
sine of Z also 0
let's try either the Z also 0 okay but
now let's try to add in divided by Z
okay so let's try this formula we
we're doing the same contour integral
around a unit radius circle of an
analytic function Co sub Z divided by Z
so I'm adding in a singularity at Z
equals zero so we just try to write this
out so that we know what we think the
answer should be okay so if we did this
integral of C of Co sub Z divided by Z
DZ what should this equal okay two pi I
times what times F evaluated at Z equals
zero which is 1 times coast of 0 so this
should equal to PI I I don't mess
anything up ok so we're integrating this
function f equals co sub Z divided by Z
around a closed contour integral and
we're testing that the Koshi integral
formula is true and it is the answer
after I integrate all thousand of these
little sectors around the circle is 0
plus 2 pi I it's exactly what we think
it should be ok it's nice you can
actually integrate these things if you
wanted to you could create some nasty
curve and integrate around that that
would still work it's a little harder to
do in MATLAB and then you can do the
same thing for the homework problem e to
the Z sine of Z over Z is a little
interesting
any idea is y sine of Z over Z is
different why is that 0
because sine of zero is zero so sine of
Z over Z is in fact analytic because the
Taylor series for your sine has you know
powers of it has a Z in every term so
you can divide that C out and you still
get a conversion Taylor series
interesting so sine of Z over Z is
analytic
okay that's basically everything I
wanted to tell you today that's a good
place to stop we have this
extraordinarily useful formula we can
prove why it's true
it's only true for Z minus a you know
it's only true if you divide by one
power of Z minus a if you had five
powers that would be different it would
be zero and we can also show that this
is true in that lab okay so next time
we're gonna start doing real difficult
integrals using this like just we're
gonna try new integrals and we're also
going to show how to do inverse Laplace
transforms by hand okay good
you